seen the video on the internet where
they're wrapping the chains around the
actual drills and that [ __ ] looks real
hard
right we're going down two miles below
the Earth how do you know you're gonna
hit it every single Energy company that
is not thinking about Bitcoin mining is
wrong I was arrested by senior year of
college it was
um it sucked the D.A basically said
we're gonna charge it with three counts
of aggravated assault and I was like Dad
let's fight this that's like look I
messed up but like felonies and so when
I came out and I realized wow this
system's really messed up and imagine if
I didn't have the financial resources I
have so I got interested in Criminal
Justice Reform a lot of us like what if
we started a for-profit prisoners that
it wasn't paid per individual and this
was pitched to a few very wealthy
individuals that everybody knows like we
can't be seen investing in a prison deal
I was like look I'm getting power I
don't give a damn this will affectuate
human Prosperity let's figure out how to
do this all right guys Bang Bang get in
here with me I'm super excited to talk
about this everyone in the world knows
that uh the American economy is made up
of so many different types of workers
businesses but one that gets [ __ ] on one
that gets completely lost uh in kind of
the controversy and the debate on a
national stage is the oil and gas field
workers and you your family so much of
what you do on a day-to-day basis uh you
interact with these people you've worked
with them for a long period of time and
so I thought a great place to start a
conversation it's just like help us
understand the oil and gas industry and
the importance of the actual field
worker themselves to sustain not only
the industry but the American economy in
general
yeah I think that's one of the most
important things I appreciate giving me
a platform to talk on this because
um really you know we talk about oil and
gas and it's obviously needed throughout
Society I think there was a lot of push
towards hey let's you know do this
energy transition but it needs to be
sustainable and part of sustainability
is profit
um so I think really kind of slowing
down and thinking about what's going on
in the field and yeah to your point so
the field workers are the guys that are
putting oil in the tanks and so really I
mean when there's a weather event
um you know those guys are overcoming
adversity they're overcoming the
elements they're actually in the field
ensuring that oil is coming out of the
ground the gas is coming out of the
ground and that gas is heating our homes
it's powering power plants which is base
load critical to powering our whole
world and you know economy so really the
field workers
um I think they're one of the most
underappreciated throughout society and
I was telling you the story earlier but
my daughter came home from school one
day
and she was like hey my friends and I
are in oil and gas and they don't like
you and I was like cool
um so here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna wake up tomorrow 5 a.m and we're
gonna go to West Texas where we've got a
Frack operation going on and to my
surprise she woke up before me was ready
to go and we drove three hours out to
West Texas and you know we got we got
there there's about 30 guys Mass amounts
of equipment going on and really I did
luckily one of our our head of
engineering was out there and I was like
Hey Walker will you introduce her to
everybody and she got to see 30 guys
that were working and I said Avery
these 30 guys they're ensuring that we
have the fuel needed to power our
current modern world and without these
individuals that wouldn't be possible
and and the oil is ten dollars we were
fracking when nobody else was there was
chaos oiled just stopped being negative
and she got to see 30 individuals who
were able to feed their families because
there was this you know Mutual benefit
of we're getting oil out and these guys
are making it making sure it happens so
um you know and I could have tried to
explain that to her but she saw that
perspective and you know made sense to
her there's an element of humanizing
these conversations that I think is
really important right
um there's a comedian who has a whole
spiel about the term Insurgent during
the war right if you say hey we're gonna
go kill insurgents everyone's like I
don't know any insurgents like Kill Them
All right but if you're like Hey we're
gonna go kill humans they're gonna Time
Out Hold On which humans why all of that
same thing when you bring it to the
National debate and it's not so much a
wartime scenario but we talk about
different Industries or different types
of workers with just this broad-based
stroke you don't know anyone in that
industry you've never met anyone you
don't understand what they do on a
day-to-day basis you may not even
understand how that industry works or
what that job entails and so therefore
it's easy to say I like this one I don't
like this one because you don't know
right you're just completely uninformed
you're ignorant and frankly most people
are just repeating what they've heard on
the mainstream media
when you look at these roles of the oil
and gas workers what are they doing on a
day-to-day basis like you you said they
helped get the oil into the tanks right
they're making sure that the natural gas
is coming out of the ground like all
these but like what are they actually
doing and I'm coming at it super
uneducated other than I've seen the
video on the internet where they're
wrapping the chains around the actual
drills and that [ __ ] looks real hard
right I worked on a double jackknife rig
and once they found out I was the boss
of son I was not allowed to throw a
chain but
um yeah so yeah I think you know there's
a few kind of key field workers and I
love you know I love the the convergence
of Bitcoin mining and oil and gas
because a lot of the names that have
emerged for these positions we're all
going to translate that over to oil okay
Bitcoin mining as well but really
there's your your pumper so after you
have drilled a well you know that is a
mechanical operation that goes thousands
of feet into the ground you set casing
which is pipe then you have fluids then
you have cement to ensure that you're
protecting the water but but one that
oil and gas didn't just come out of the
ground that's a mechanical operation
things are going to break so what a
pumper does is they're proactively
checking on the well if there's a leak
leaks happen then the pumper is our
first line of defense to ensuring hey
let's catch it before it gets bad and
then remediate the land so really the
pumper kind of floats around and has
several different Wells and this covers
a large geographic area and there's talk
of let's automate that you know and of
course there's efficiencies that you
know choil we're evaluating but you
can't ever replace the human that goes
out there makes observations and then is
able to assess what went wrong or what
is about to go wrong so that's kind of
another big you've you know you've got
to anticipate and that's where
experience matters so the pumper is in
charge of making sure that the wells are
performing performing safely and you
know kind of the first line of defense
on what could go wrong
um and I kind of think about the pumper
like I think about you know somebody
checking on their Bitcoin lines all
right but we'll get there uh but yeah
and then there's the roughneck and what
a roughneck does great name it's a yeah
yeah roughneck is one of the greatest I
don't know what they do but I want to be
that guy so what a rough deck does is
they're kind of a modern Nomad so their
job is to operate the drilling rig so
they're the guys on the drilling rig and
that's an offshore drilling wig or
that's an onshore drilling rig and so
really they're the guys and there's a
few different
um ways to manage their schedules uh but
a lot of guys do you know three eight
hour ships and this is a huge Capital
Investments millions of dollars to own a
trailing rig and so you want that
working all 24 7. I mean these guys are
working over Christmas over Thanksgiving
over New Year's over the Super Bowl I
mean this is a 24 7 operation and so
what they're doing is there's a few
different types of Roughnecks there's a
tool pusher who's in charge and then
um you know you've got the weasel the
new guy but really those are the guys
that are Manning the mechanical
operations of putting a hole in the
ground so you're gonna you're going into
the ground and then you know you've got
to connect pipe or um drill pipe and so
you've got a drill bit that has to go
down we're going down two miles below
the Earth that is just CL you know look
out and identify what is a two mile
marker we're going that far down and
then we go two miles sideways and so you
go two miles down and then two miles
sideways to actually hit some of these
oil deposits yep it's at the right
terminal as your oil deposit reservoirs
reservoirs yeah I'm only half of sport
um all right so two miles down two miles
sideways but when you do that how do you
know that you're going to hit it that is
like the big question that when I see
this I'm like I didn't realize it was
two miles first of all but second of all
like the pinpoint accuracy to hit this
stuff how big is the reservoir and like
do you ever Miss
uh yeah you definitely missed that
that's okay there's so many awesome
capabilities and guys and girls in this
industry but uh to ensure you don't miss
you want to have a damn good drilling
engineer but at the same time you want
to have someone on this team that's an
operations geologist so the drilling
engineer is really kind of the
quarterback ensuring the drilling is
done safely prudently and efficiently
um and really we've got a great drilling
I mean our drill engine I'm gonna brag
on him one of the things I really liked
is when you have a certain kpi which is
a lot of drilling Engineers like to go
fast because that you can measure well
if you drill too fast then you're going
to drill a janky hole and that means
when you're producing it the pumper is
going to have a harder time so you
really want a humble individual that is
a high performer and that's exactly what
we've got his name is David Dean he's an
awesome human and I was incredibly
impressed the first time I had breakfast
with him is just his humility and I've
seen it in action where he's a good
communicator because it's intense we're
moving fast so the drilling engineer is
really setting that kind of framework
for how do we do this right and ensuring
the Roughnecks the tool pushers and then
the directional company
so what a directional company does is
they literally are a service company
that has the technology to measure where
you are so you're down two miles and
we're actually going some people are
going to three miles is that because
there's less oil closer to the surface
now like we've been going and getting
oil for a while and so we have to keep
going deeper and deeper to find more of
these reservoirs it's not just deeper so
it really is this amazing study of human
Ingenuity so historically you would
drill down and you didn't have to drill
like we literally there was oil seeps on
the ground and people were like oh
where's the oil on the ground let's put
a hole there yep and that was like a
novel concept and then a liquid battery
came out and people were like oh great
we can make this into productive and
that obviously ushered in the industrial
revolution that's when I would have been
successful in the oil and gas industry
is when you could just walk around and
be like oh there's oil put a hole there
like yeah after that I'm out and that's
where people are like oh Bitcoin is
crazy I can't oh my gosh this is like
magic internet money it's like guys
literally people use 2 to imagine trying
to explain oil and gas to someone like
Hey we're gonna go drill a hole and a
liquid battery is going to come out oh
and we need a you know inflation
adjusted millions of dollars to go to an
like West Texas that is the flattest
someone literally conceptualized an idea
in their mind that underneath that were
mountains of oil and you know that
obviously ushered in the industrial
revolution and helped us win World War
II
um when you see that happening is that
why people in Texas are so predisposed
to
um what I'll consider like the American
ideals and eat those because there's a
lot of alignment there but also why
they're so predisposed to uh being
receptive to bitcoin I think it has a
lot to do
if you know one capabilities if like
what we've done like going two miles
down and two miles out three miles out
that's really challenging that takes a
coordinated effort of of
several types of employees Services
Consultants companies and so really when
people are like oh Bitcoin mining it's
so hard what would what are what the oil
and gas industry has done is light years
it is the most advanced capabilities
companies in the world I mean we have
overcome you're talking about offshore
going down you know several miles then
heating the seabed floor then going down
you know another five miles I mean these
are orders of magnitude more complex
projects than anything the world has
faced so when we so to me it all comes
down to capabilities we in the oil and
gas business we've seen individuals
overcome significant obstacles to power
our modern world and really you know
again kind of goes back to like we're
never gonna We will never run out of oil
molecules period full stop end of
argument we might run out of economic
oil and I think that goes back to Julian
Simon's principle of cornucopian
Economics which when oil goes up it's
saying two things
find more of me and compete or or so
find more me or find another resource to
compete so when oil was running out in
2008 or you know gas was running out we
were literally building spending
billions of dollars to import natural
gas and then what happened
some dudes out of West Texas and the
Barnett shell said hey let's drill
sideways let's apply Innovation let's
apply technology the price signal has
gone up the incentive is greater boom so
we're not running out of natural gas we
got way too much and I think the same
thing happened with the oil business you
know we were running out of oil and then
everyone's like oh we did it with gas
can we do it with oil hell yeah human
Innovation was applied and oil would be
significantly higher had we not had the
culture we have in America and the
property rights to unleash that
Innovation you mentioned Julian Simon
and I didn't know who that was until you
were telling me about them and you I
think quote that you used was Julian
Simon is the greatest economic uh
individual that no one knows right he's
the greatest Economist no one knows so
Julian Simon is the greatest Economist
and no one knows who the hell is Julian
Simon he really
um was the antithesis to the malthusian
idea that we have too many people on
this planet
um so really he took the stance and he
made a famous bet on kind of the future
of commodity prices where he said look
in the long run all Commodities Trend
towards zero because of human Innovation
and I think history is repeat you know
shown this multiple times so he wrote a
book called uh the ultimate resource but
the ultimate Resource One and the
ultimate resource two and really he
popularized and really conceptualized
these ideas that we don't need top-down
management we need more people and so
really the greatest resource is the
human mind so we need more people we
need more people with more ideas
equipped with liberty and so you know
one of his quotes is our company quote
where it's like individuals equipped
with liberty and freedom they can exert
their will on you know their ecosystem
and there's this Mutual benefit that we
all and and I think this has played out
I mean I like the example of going back
to whaling literally the whales were
going extinct because of whale fat and
that was used to power the world and
then somebody found this thing called
kerosene and all of a sudden the whales
didn't go extinct you know that was not
out of the goodness of their heart that
was there was a better product let the
market compete we saw this at the same
time with we were people were
deforesting Europe to power they were
using wood you know that is archaic but
and they were deforesting all of Europe
and then all of a sudden someone was
like I mean they were designing boats to
go to America to pick up wood and come
back and then all of a sudden coal was
discovered and that helped where we
didn't you know DeForest everything so I
think when people talk about CO2 or you
know emissions this is not something
Society hasn't faced and in fact the
people that are going to solve it are
the individuals with resources endowed
with liberty and capabilities at the oil
and gas companies what's fascinating to
me about you is uh you're very well
educated you uh have this uh very um
kind of sympathetic view towards the oil
and gas field worker you understand the
importance of the actual people on the
ground doing the work keeping the
American economy power forward and
running and kind of building this huge
economic machine the world's never seen
before uh but at the same time uh you
run a business and you run a business in
uh a pretty unique way compared to the
rest of the world but you've got a
couple of uh folks that I think you've
kind of gotten a crash course from and
Charles Koch is one of them who when I
say that name most people think of
politics and donations and all this kind
of stuff but they actually don't know
that Charles Koch and his brother have
built one of the largest if not the
largest private company in America I
think it does you know 100 plus billion
dollars in Revenue a year and when you
actually start to unpack how they did
that
the MBA that you can get from Simply
understanding how well run that
organization is how principled that
organization is how they treat their
employees how they treat their Partners
how they treat uh their leaders is
unlike most companies in America so
maybe talk a little bit about uh that
organization and what you've learned
from them and maybe Charles himself
yeah
um I mean Charles Koch will go down as
one of the greatest philosophers and
Business Leaders and philanthropic
leaders the world's ever seen
um really I'm incredibly blessed I was
posting uh
libertarian-ish things in 2016-17 I
always try to be very respectful and uh
one of my friends called me and said hey
you clearly don't have enough friends
why don't you come to this dinner and I
went to this dinner and it was it was a
dinner sponsored by uh Charles Coke's
philanthropic group called Stand
Together and at that dinner I met Aid
under and my wife and I showed up we
made eight other individuals who who
really cared and weren't just LARPing
and complaining it was there are
problems in the world what are we gonna
do about it and so I I I mean that was
just a supercharge of like that wow
these people they're you know they I
mean it was an incredibly diverse crowd
everyone had different ideas but there
was no complaining it was how do we get
better and so then
um you know started going to this you
know these events called Stand Together
and I just remember interacting with
everyone at this philanthropic group and
being incredibly impressed with you know
even a little thing like one time a
whiteboard fell and one of the employees
from the very far back came back grabbed
the Whiteboard and put it up and I was
just like how is everyone such a high
performer here and so respectful and
um there's also if you you know if you
I'm a member of stand together because
it's one of the easiest organizations
I've ever felt about I mean it was just
such an easy win what is it stand
together so stand together is a
philanthropic organization that is
focused on backing social entrepreneurs
so really what Charles Koch and his team
did was they developed capabilities over
decades on how to build long-term value
and profit matters but it's really you
know we think about things in a binary
way of for-profit not-for-profit and I
think that's a flawed Dynamic and really
it's culture how do you build culture so
I had no idea what company culture was I
never thought about it but I remember I
was meeting with um and what his
philosophy is uh really market-based
management or principle-based management
and it's apply by basically what distill
what made America great and then apply
that to any ecosystem
and so really when I started interacting
with the stand together people I also
got introduced to some former Executives
from Coke Industries and they just spoke
the most truth and wisdom I mean it was
just like unbelievable on the knowledge
and I was all you know my dad was
you know he his dad died in a young age
and he just had to work and his whole
life he felt like he was trying to
survive even though he built a massive
business but he loved working
um but you know so he instilled in me
this just like hey be effective get
stuff done and you know so fun to work
with my dad towards the end of his life
because he built I kept reiterating you
know it's hard going through change I
was trying to change stuff at choya
um but he he started to see that I got
to take time off reflect build
philosophy heavily influenced by
market-based management and stand
together in Coke Industries
and apply that to to not only my
personal life my business life my
philanthropic of how do we create Mutual
benefit through society and specifically
I'll never forget so
um I was arrested my senior year of
college it was um it sucked what did you
do
um I got in a motorcycle accident in a
parade and
um you know I heard some kids and that
sucked because I was making a good smile
before that but I got to go to jail and
I'll never forget I I walked in feeling
really sorry for myself because I was
charged with three
the D.A basically said we're going to
charge with three counts of aggravated
assault and I was like Dad let's fight
this that's like look I messed up but
like felonies and um
that was one of the first times I saw my
dad cry and my criminal defense attorney
was like you can't win this Gideon
you you have to plead down and it was
also um but yeah so that so anyway I go
into jail
and I tell the story and people's like
how long are you in there uh like three
hours but my two white parents who love
each other who raised me
um and I had awesome criminal defense
they took me to jail and so when I came
out it didn't happen overnight but I
realized wow this system's really messed
up and imagine if I didn't have the
financial resources I have so I got
interested in Criminal Justice Reform
that's actually where I first got
introduced to Charles and his philosophy
is
um I saw that he was interested in
Criminal Justice Reform and then you
know years later I get invited to see
him it was just like a an amazing thing
what does he do around Criminal Justice
Reform it okay so really there's
something called the first step act
which basically got
it it equipped people with the resources
to get thousands of people out of jail
who who should not be in jail so our
criminal justice system is totally
screwed up that there's no doubt but
it's so big how do we I mean there are
like we talk about America which is a
dichotomous relationship of like okay
we're the freest nation in the world but
we also incarcerate more people than any
other Nation like that's insane and
that's a problem and it's one of the
greatest travesties of our time
um and so I also like Criminal Justice
Reform because it's mutually beneficial
there is no tribe like okay there's you
know okay we got you're a Democrat okay
you like Criminal Justice Reform you
know lower the amount of time for
non-violent drug offenses and then oh
you're a Republican and you are fiscally
conservative uh well prison is a really
expensive way of making people worse and
so
um so Charles and his team a guy named
Mark Holden actually was Coast general
counsel and he approached Charles and
said hey this is really screwed up I'm a
lawyer I worked at a jail I want to
change this and so Mark spun out started
developing capabilities up in Washington
and really for decades they built
resources relationships and were
prepared and a few years ago
there was a woman named Alice Marie
Johnson so Alice
um
she's one of the most amazing people
I've ever met and she was in jail
because she got in put in a bad
situation she was a grandma her mother
at the time and she she sold drugs and
she approached and it was her first time
ever events and you know the D.A said
we're gonna we're gonna punish you and
she said this insane I'm not doing a
pleading down to 10 years or something
like that and so she fought it and they
punished her they sent a message which
is do not fight the system take your
slap on the wrist of 10 years so she was
set to be in jail forever so anyway we
threw a fundraiser my wife and I did
kind of incubate some criminal justice
non-profits
and I remember seeing a video of Alice
Marie Johnson played at my house and
she's just this sweet sweet lady and
she's talking about she messed up and
but how she's sorry and I gave this
speech in my house I think it was 2016
about how I'm you know or no 17. I was
like you know we everyone in this room I
invited all my parents friends all my
you know all my Bitcoin friends all my
oil friends like anybody that's curious
and had resources I wanted you there and
um actually Parker Lewis orange killed
me that night
um but it was really fair the mayor I
mean and it was so fun because so many I
got to bring in so many people that it
wasn't about Bitcoin it was about how do
we Elevate human prosperity and here's
an injustice and I remember saying
everyone can have a small impact on
ensuring people like Alice and the jail
wouldn't even let her video in we had to
play a recording and I was like everyone
can have a small impact on ensuring
people like Alice get out of jail and
also stay out of jail and then like a
year later I'm in a stand together
conference hugging her how'd that happen
well how it had to and is because it I
was a very very very small part of
elevating a dialogue my wife and I were
um but really what people don't fully
appreciate is the first step Act was
about to die it was there were some
people held up on it and I remember the
night it was held up I was texting Mark
Holden some leaders that stand together
some leaders at Americas for Prosperity
um and I was like hey how can I help how
can I help and then I'll never forget
Mark was like Gideon we've been
preparing for this moment for a very
long time you know appreciate your
feedback and they got it over the Finish
Line they got it done and it wasn't one
individual it wasn't Mark wasn't Charles
it was a coordinated effort but all the
groups I was talking to were incubated
by Charles cope so anyone who got out of
jail they don't give a damn what you
know who got him out of jail
um you know so really and you know
president Trump signed that he pardoned
Alice Marie and Alice was the
inspiration I mean
you've got to bring her on she like she
was literally I don't know if you've
ever been to jail it's really
dehumanizing and I've been in inside of
several jails uh multiple times with my
wife working on some you know it's just
dehumanizing you know and no one's
getting out of that better I mean you're
not even allowed to win kovid you
couldn't even hug your daughter so
there's a program called girls embracing
mothers Jim and you know so sweet um we
you know my wife uh and my kids made
these blankets or got blankets and it
was so hard to get them into the jail
but when we got him inside the jail
the mothers got to spend time with their
daughters and work on a little project
together and like it's the humanizing
element of it yes that basically when
you do that all of a sudden now you
bring back not only for the mothers but
also for the daughters and that's where
um Bernie Barnett
um has a quote that I I steal a lot of
quotes I try to give people credit sorry
none of them but it's like it's not just
one person Goes to Jail the whole family
goes to jail so we're taking people
we're moving them we're placing them
around and you know we need uh you know
my brothers are recovering heroin addict
yeah
that doesn't happen overnight it's a
lack of community it's all and it's it's
all these things so we have to keep the
families together yeah and we have to
think about that and that should be
considered it I do think that this is a
really interesting
um place maybe that our society is in
right so uh it's very well documented
the challenges with broken homes and and
the lack of uh two parents and all that
and I always careful to say like some
people uh arrive at that situation by
choice some people arrive at it uh not
by choice they're put in that situation
and so which however you get there you
get there and I think that there's a lot
of uh work that's being done on you know
what can we do to help these families
that that are there whether they chose
to be there or not we need to help them
but also there's this interconnectedness
of we live a sedentary uh life people
are not out exercising they don't eat
healthy well why they're not eating
healthy well they probably don't make
enough money in many cases to actually
be able to afford healthy food right
then all of a sudden you add in things
like uh um the mental health issues or
the mental health issues uh because if
you just were by yourself uh you would
have the mental health issues because
we're poisoning brains with social media
and and electronics and devices uh then
you add in uh criminal behavior and then
drugs and and you start to like build
this picture where you're like hold on a
second here there's a lot of issues that
people face in society but are there one
two three different things that if we
just tackle them we actually can have a
first principle solution right and I
think a lot about like Criminal Justice
Reform I've had people on who are public
defenders I've had people on who have
been in uh jail or in prison I've had
people on who are lawyers who help put
people in prison right and FBI agents
like all these different people are in
and around this stuff
and when I pull back for a second I
think to myself you gotta attack it from
both sides it feels like you got to have
what I call like the Band-Aid solution
hey you're already in the situation we
can't go back let's get you out right
how do we actually help you given the
situation you're in at the same time how
do we have a first principle solution to
prevent the next wave of people from
ending up in the same situation and I
think one as I've learned about this
stuff and talked to a whole bunch of
different people one of the things
everyone agrees on it's like we gotta
have a society where there are a set of
rules what those rules are will be
debated but there has to be a set of
rules it has to be enforced and that
some people's vision of that is like
lots of rules some people's vision of
that is almost no rules but somewhere
there's got to be rules and and they've
got to be enforced that whatever Society
agrees upon
but what it feels like is in the pursuit
of individuals trying to do their job
they end up making decisions that they
don't understand the repercussions and I
think a lot about you know the drug laws
is probably one of the best examples
where we have people who are sitting in
jail for literally a decade Plus for
non-violent possession in some cases and
each story is different each you know
kind of detail is different
but when you look at like that one
situation you're like I don't think
that's what actually the people who
created the laws I don't think that's
law enforcement I don't think that's
what Society intended to be the outcome
but we got here and so unraveling it's
way harder than creating a situation but
it feels like some of the work you guys
have done and uh Charles and and kind of
his organizations are doing is like
trying to attack it from both sides is
that a fair way to think about it or not
just both sides all sides I mean I think
that was like you know if you're a
curious individual and you care you want
a better world it's incredibly
overwhelming where do we start okay well
if I help in education well then you
still got criminal justice or mental but
but I think that was one of the coolest
things when I walked in to stand
together is there were type A get stuff
done people in every Arena educate I'll
never forget one of the first guys I met
um I forgot what state he was from it
was somewhere on the East Coast he was
like I didn't like the school system in
my state so I and I had the resources to
do something so I built a competitive
school like and I'm just like oh what
that's possible and I think and I think
that's what they're you know setting a
good vision is really important and like
giving everyone like Hey how do we work
on this and let's all start trending and
I think one of the things you talk you
talk about is you know these rules in
society and I think that's where I'm
many of us are trying to popularize look
there's uh there's for-profit non-profit
but that's too black and white things
are complicated so we're trying to build
out this framework of top-down Solutions
versus bottom-up Solutions and I think
you know an example is
um well the oil and gas business I mean
why did the American Shale Revolution
why did the Shale Revolution the energy
Renaissance happen in America and it's
because there was and Russia doesn't
have bottom-up Solutions Saudi Arabia
has better rocks they're way better
rocks globally California has some of
the best I think that Los Angeles Basin
has the highest oil per square
sedimentary foot in the world West Texas
doesn't have the best rocks it's what do
they have they have a culture that
equips bought they have property rights
which gives a line of sight to you know
change so there isn't one person in
America dictating energy policy there is
a bunch of entrepreneurs who are
equipped with profit and a vision of
creating value so I think this idea of
bottom up can it be applied you know
it's the same thing like we have Federal
Draconian drug laws get rid of them let
the states set that what that should be
so I think which kind of goes back to
the philosophy I was working on which my
wife told me to not talk about it so
but um how do we have you know a
different conversation which is not
for-profit non-profit you know
um uh what's kind of another good
example is like coveted policy you know
the federal you know there were federal
government hey let's do this you know
and it really it's like hey what does
the community want to decide so I think
getting the closer we can push decision
rights to the individual individuals it
can be scary but we know what's best for
our lives when I think like you know
that's kind of another reason why I like
Bitcoin mining on the grid grids are
getting more complicated and you had
top-down Federal renewable mandates and
incentives that CR that have absolutely
distorted the market and I reached chaos
and grids that doesn't mean Renewables
don't have a place but Bitcoin mining is
a bottom-up solution that can help
balance grids and I think you know right
now I mean utilities are some of the
slowest they all know this so the smart
most archaic and then you got us you
know ratchet bitcoiners who are like Hey
we're gonna come in and change
everything and it's scary but at the
same time we've got to start and so
anyway I just like that framework of
bottom-up solutions so this bottom-up
solution I think is really interesting
because every company started bottoms up
right even the ones that are planned in
boardrooms or with large Investments or
spin-offs or whatever
it's individuals with an idea who are
willing to invest Capital time and
energy to build something they believe
the market wants and in a capitalist
system
the market is the ultimate feedback
machine it either wants it or it doesn't
and I think that there are many people
uh Vivek ramaswamy is a good example uh
who's been on and talked about we now
have people making decisions at
companies that are not about the market
it's not about economics it's now about
how do I fulfill these other mandates
and his point
I'll paraphrase and hopefully don't get
it wrong is
your job as a company is to make profit
for your shareholders focus on that that
does not mean that you should destroy
everything else and not worry about
everything else but in many cases if you
are optimizing for the highest amount of
profit for your shareholders that leads
you to invest for r d purposes because
over the long term you have to be
Innovative you have to drive a change to
your business you have to actually go
ahead and develop things uh you actually
want the best people and so everyone
ends up not looking alike or having the
same background the same experiences
right all these like things that I think
generally Society is like hey that's a
good idea
his point is if you focus on driving
profit the market kind of drives those
changes faster than actually having
these top-down mandates and my favorite
example is minimum wage minimum wage in
America is still 7.25 cents
and it's been that way for over a decade
almost like 13 14 years now
Amazon pays close to 20 bucks an hour as
their minimum wage like 17 and a half 18
bucks we have politicians that are
advocating for minimum wage in America
to go from 725 to 15 15 is already
behind because guess what one of the
largest employers in America is already
paying 17 and a half 18 by the time the
politicians get around to making a 15
Amazon's gonna be paying 20 21 22 and so
the market has done a better job of
moving minimum wage
than the politicians have and so it's an
argument that like well actually maybe
what we should do is remove minimum wage
and allow the free market to go ahead
and operate because guess what if you go
talk to a restaurant tour right now
they're not talking about minimum wage
they're talking about I used to pay a
dishwasher 12 there's a restaurant tour
uh here I won't use his name because
he's he's scared to come on the podcast
but he told me he said look we used to
have uh dishwashers 12 bucks an hour
then I started off from 13 14 15 16. 17
I can't get anyone to show up I can't
get someone to stick with the job and so
guess what's going to happen he's going
to keep raising the price of what he's
going to pay that employee until he
finds someone who can do the job and
that free market Dynamic to me feels
almost exactly what you're talking about
of like this Bottoms Up approach let the
market operate and if you do that
usually you actually arrive at the
solutions faster even in a socialist a
communist a democratic a capitalist
Society whatever the top down is not
only sometimes doesn't achieve it but
it's slower even if it gets there then
the market itself will actually
determine right yeah no I I think that's
a great example of you know bottom up
and I think of course I think we can
both agree there's some laws people you
know businesses individual visuals can
take advantage of others and weakness
but I think that doesn't mean that you
know we shouldn't I do think that
minimum wage and many of these things we
can set a better framework to where it's
like look have and I think it goes back
to the Fiat system of like and that was
one of the weirdest things I was like I
hate inflation like it is the most evil
evil thing and it punishes the most
disadvantaged but it's really really
hard to talk to a single mother
struggling to pay daycare of hey you
know what you should hate the Federal
Reserve and quantitative easing you know
so I think that's been a humbling thing
as well of like they're really tough
discussions there's a huge education
need
um and yeah just a general lack of
incentives to to change but I think you
know even you know a business I'd even I
don't you know I like to I don't even
profit matters and I think profit is
very allows for more sustainability but
I I talk in terms of the purpose of our
business is to create long-term Mutual
beneficial value because cause there's a
lot of stuff and we're a private company
so I don't give a damn about the next
couple years I'm thinking 10 20 years
out how do we do what's best in a
mutually beneficial way for our company
and its stakeholders but when you think
when I when I change the lens to Value I
mean we were very philanthropic
organization that does not help our
short-term profit and it probably
doesn't even help our long term but I
think we in society you know Business
Leaders individuals people in the field
we all have a moral obligation to think
about people and the communities we
operate in so I do and I think that's
one of the problems with the public
company is they don't you know they've
got thousands of people that can bark oh
you did that and it's short-sightedness
so I do hope to see many many more
companies staying private and with a
smaller ownership base to where you can
effectuate and really be more attentive
to hugely beneficial value creation do
you think the American economy would be
better off if we had all private
companies or more private companies than
so many public companies absolutely hi I
mean one of the problems in you know
just the general archetypal problem in
society is this High Time preference and
I think cheap money has accelerated that
so I think when you're public you have a
very high time preference you are
focused on the next quarter I cannot
imagine over the last few years some of
the conversations and the pressure
that's been going on in boardrooms with
ESG and you know mandates and other just
crazy chaos but I think if more
companies can stay private and not focus
so much on how do we get fast big fast
and debt you know debt can help but it's
also very very dangerous and so I think
the more companies that can you know not
be so I mean the American to me the
American dream is not
um you know the billionaires of the
world who came from nothing it's the guy
that came from India who came here got a
job working at a big company and can go
back to visit his parents and has a few
kids and he gets to go take them to
Disneyland like that to me is the
American dream my granddad was the
American dream like he came from nothing
he overcame adversity and he's created a
ton of value throughout Society but no
one's ever heard of him that's okay talk
about choya the the business that your
family runs um it's got a fascinating
backstory in terms of how you guys get
to where you are
um how did it start what was your
grandfather's story so my grand uh my
grandfather uh in when he was in sixth
grade his dad passed away so he had to
go to work he was the The Breadwinner
for the family and you know was
forced to become an entrepreneur and so
really he worked at some big companies
he worked for General crude out in wink
back in like 1921
um you know I had 200 employees he used
to go to the train station with armed
guards to pick up the the cash that
would pay the guys every two weeks
um but he then became an entrepreneur he
saved up and he bought a small drilling
rig and he started contract drilling for
some of the guys out in East Texas
during the East Texas boom
um and really you know my dad was was
birthed in the East Texas craziness
and so my my granddad was terrible with
money he found a lot of oil but then he
went bankrupt multiple times so really
but but he he was able to provide my dad
a really good education my dad got to go
to high school and then my dad got to go
to college and get an MBA and so
um but my dad grew up in field
operations he had immense respect for
all the guys in the field
um because he lived it he saw it and so
there was no one sharper than my dad on
the whole how do you how do you get oil
out of the ground because he lived it
and how important right like to me I
always think of like people who end up
rising to run these organizations like
he
built a body of experience he built a
body of knowledge from doing the work
right and and it feels like given where
he was able to take the company over
time it was built on almost like an
apprenticeship model right of like I
actually have done this and when I
talked to these employees I know exactly
what they're doing because I did it
myself before I ended up getting into
the leadership position right there was
not a single person we used to say my
dad had 50 uh direct reports because he
talked to everyone at the company and we
all knew he was the smartest guy because
he'd done it every single thing he was
doing someone to do was something he had
done
um I mean all the way suit to nuts from
Prospect to pipeline my dad lived it and
I think that was um yeah it was just
great seeing that growing up and yeah my
dad built a huge business um
and so talk a little bit as he's going
through the field operations he's kind
of growing how do how do we get from him
uh doing the work to eventually building
the big company uh so really
um my when my dad was 29 his dad passed
away and I've got the balance sheet it's
like
abysmal you know there was a couple
thousand bucks in the bank and then
there was like a ten thousand or fifty
thousand dollar accounts receivable and
then you know like a thirty thousand
accounts payable it was Rob and Peter to
pay Paul and
um you know his first five years you
know he was just trying to survive
um and then really my dad like I said he
got his MBA he learned Finance
um we almost moved to Midland Texas uh
but he decided to stay in Dallas because
that's where investors were and so uh
you know my dad started out doing a
third for a quarter which was kind of an
early Private equity-ish Structure for
oil and gas guys
um how does that work so really it's uh
you find an investor you know the doctor
is the lawyers and you put up they put
up a third of the money uh to drill the
well in exchange for a quarter of the
ownership in it so it's kind of like a
front-end
um uh private Equity structure to where
hey we'll put up a million dollars but
then the operator or like a choya would
keep a quarter ownership so there was an
incentive and you could structure us all
kinds of ways but day one you got skin
in the game and my dad would always keep
um you know at least 50 percent of his
deals
um but yeah so he just he just military
he knew what he was good at he drilled
about 50 Wells a year for the last 10 10
years of his life I mean he and he just
even on his uh on his deathbed he passed
away from cancer I mean he was just
militant I mean we just want to drill
one more well
and um we really please don't drilled as
well and uh you know we just we'd been
growing our team and everyone was I mean
my dad was just one of a kind with a
last three wildcatters so we drill you
know we're spending millions of dollars
and we drill this well 6 000 feet and we
had problems and I was like Hey Dad
there's problems let's call it
this might be my last damn well you
slide the rig and you drill that hole
and so that's what we did and then we
drilled another 6 000 feet and it was a
dry hole and at the same time we had a
bunch of unplugged Miners and he was
just screaming from his bed I mean it
was he wanted to be with his family and
he wanted to ensure that I did not
become a country club bomb
was that a concern of his like just in
general of like you've built something
and you know that you're going to hand
it over to the next generation and uh
the joke is always you know uh the first
generation builds of the second
generation keeps going the third
generation gives it all back right of uh
businesses across industry is that
something that you guys talked about
like uh over the years he many times the
third generation losing it is something
that
has been hammered into me and so I think
you know my dad did a really good job of
he never told me go into the oil
business he was like I love the oil
business you go figure out what you love
so of course you know I said oh I'm
gonna go do my own thing but I'll never
forget I sat down to get some feedback
and just wisdom from a guy named Hans
helmert okay who was like a third fourth
generation guy who built professional
has a massive drilling company called
Homer campaign I was like hey I'm
thinking about going back to work for my
dad you work for your dad
um can I come up to Tulsa and just pick
your brain he goes absolutely so I flew
to Tulsa you know he introduced me to
all the guys at his team and you know
different divisions and then that night
we went to dinner and
um he Utica Square and he was he was
like Gideon you know we talked he
instilled wisdom and then finally he's
like look Gideon no one has a more
vested interest in your success than
your dad
and he was like you can go work
somewhere else but your dad's gonna care
way more than anybody so even though my
dad and I didn't communicate effectively
at the time that was like oh man okay so
I was like all right I'm gonna go back
to work for my dad I had a vision a
strategy I pitched my dad he said Greg
let's go and so yeah that was some of
the most Blissful years was just running
around the Permian I don't have a damn I
mean our board approval process was you
know me barking at my dad hey we gotta
buy these leases over in Howard County
or Dawson County and then if I you know
if I yelled loud enough or had enough
conviction then he'd say okay and that
was our approval process it's funny
because
um uh recently we had a deal
we made an investment years ago and the
founder sent me an email and he goes
we're doing a transaction on Wednesday
it's like on Friday before I'm like okay
uh is a good transaction or bad
basically and uh he goes in this deal uh
you guys are gonna get some money back
uh she made some money uh but you have
the option to roll forward 30 percent
and I only have one question for him I
said what are you doing
I said I'm rolling mine I'm just
enrolling it right and there is this
element of like the skin in the game the
conviction level the the the signals
that actually other people will give you
now do I know it's the right decision or
not no I have no clue but that's about
as strong of a signal as I'm gonna get
out of any of the other data points I
could look at or or any of this stuff is
somebody who's near it in it and thought
about it more than I have and probably
will
what are they doing do what they do yeah
and I think that's another
I've been humbled many many times but I
think just experience I think a lot of
us you know information social media is
still liquid we see a lot of things we
want things fast High Time preference
but I've been humbled by a lot of the
mistakes I've made and there's just
something I mean I read a lot of books
books uh my father is famous for saying
Gideon quit your book [ __ ] and put oil
in the tanks because I have great Theory
joke uh but um but yeah that just
experience and I think one of the most
the you know in the wake of my Dad's
passing it was just so humbling how much
he was handling and you know I just had
really I was naive and I think you know
I do miss the
the fighting and the just you know but
we always respected each other when he
passes away and you step in you take
over the whole business and you're gonna
run this thing like what is that
transition period like and what I think
is interesting
um people hear about business
transitions they hear about uh the
second or third generation taking over
like the family business I don't think
people quite understand the [ __ ] that
goes on in this right you're usually
especially private companies that are
family held that usually they got pretty
good records but maybe it's not as good
as a public company obviously uh the
teams usually end up deferring to uh
whoever like the patriarchal matriarch
or the family is like there's all these
Dynamics to it what was your experience
like kind of stepping in to run the
business this episode is brought to you
by eight sleep good sleep is a game
changer and the eighth sleep pod is the
best sleep machine I sleep on it every
single night a great night of sleep
allows you to be healthier be more
arrested and have more energy throughout
the day and on the brand new eight sleep
pod 3 you can sleep as cold as 55
degrees Fahrenheit or as hot as 110
degrees Fahrenheit that's the secret of
thermoregulation better sleep better
energy get yourself an eat sleep you can
go to eatsleep.com pump today to go
ahead and get 150 off your order
eightsleep.com pump not only do I sleep
on it every night it literally changed
my life and I begged the founder so let
me invest in the company eightsleep.com
go get yourself an eight sleep pod and
get a better night of sleep well we're
still one year in I'd say we're still
deep in a transition but okay really you
know I was very lucky we sold a deal in
2016 which is when I took time off and
got into Bitcoin mining but I you know
co-founded this Bitcoin mining company
learned a ton that I was so unaware of
and then when we sold that
um and I think like 2018 19 maybe
um I basically came back to my dad and
said hey I am at the same time I got an
education on company culture so I was
like Hey Dad I am now equipped with a
dialogue or a language you know I really
want to come back to choya you run the
whole thing what what if we built a
management team to support you and so
really this idea of like let's build a
team to support you and you know my dad
was in his 70s and he years before he
wasn't ready to slow down but he was
really like when I had that conviction I
had the vision I had a lot more
professionalization I agree and so I I
basically pitched him on let's bring on
let's change company culture uh more
into you know kind of what I've learned
but also you know you moving from
authoritarian tell everyone what to do
to give feedback and of course you can
overrule everyone but just the general
let's shift and get some decision rights
off your plate and he was very open to
that it was hard we hired a third party
intermediary but so luckily before he
and really the goal was a couple of
years he was going to slow down spend
time with my mom and
um the grandkids but um
then he you know
we found out he had cancer and three
months later he was gone and so it
happened really fast but if we didn't
have that management team if we wouldn't
have the Foreside if I hadn't gotten
plugged in to stand together I wouldn't
have had the capabilities if I didn't
have the support of my wife who's she's
actually worked at big companies that is
super professional
um so she's giving me a lot of feedback
but also lives are good for that oh my
gosh yeah I mean my wife and I are so
values aligned it's unbelievable and she
slows me down it annoys me but it's a
good annoyance
um it's and so really my my my dad and I
already had officially structured some
things in place mechanically which was
no Dividends are going to come out of
this company we're pretty hardcore
committed to long-term value creation so
when he passed there was it was very
clear that you know and when you know my
family and I talked about Hey Lloyd dad
did everything
do we sell the business and I think
um
if I wouldn't have met a lot of the
people that I've mentioned through this
we would have sold the business but I
uh thankfully my with my family support
you know they were like let's let's do
this so really we decided to double down
on you know
technology and culture and really really
hard things but my brother Caleb
um he'd spent you know he was trying to
find himself we're all trying to like
run away from our fathers and all that
but you know he got some great
experience at some other companies and I
got an MBA down in Acton but before my
dad got sick he was um we called him
like Chief of Staff but really he was my
dad's [ __ ] it's a joke
okay might need to add that one out but
I love you but but really Caleb coming
on he had skills I didn't have I'm like
always you know if I wouldn't have been
born into a wealthy family I'd be you
know a theoretical physicist or a PhD
like Professor so I'm very focused on
Theory and philosophy that's very fun
for me setting a vision but my brother
had and my my dad actually told me uh
years ago he was very mad at me and he
goes your brother needs to run this
company not you and you knew that's like
kind of hard to hear but um and I don't
know if my dad was trolling me or if he
was you know a person confident was he
right absolutely my brother has so many
capabilities I mean you know it's been
an awesome example of complementary
capabilities so you know my brother's
just a better Communicator than I am
um and he's you know he's very focused I
mean even I was like I'm gonna go this
other you know event here in a couple
months he was like how's that how is
that going to create value for Troya and
I was like damn I hate hearing that
because I love going to conferences but
he's a really good sounding board and
you know I really respect his opinion
and he's gained a lot of the respect I
mean he you know he doesn't have to you
know none of us have to you know
continue running the business we do
because I don't have any hobbies I like
building stuff
um and my my brother Caleb but also just
the support of my brother Luke like I
said you know
um I'm really proud of my brother
because he's got a daughter he's leading
and you know we've had a good
relationship for the last year and his
just even his support and him you know
showing up to the Christmas party and
asking he's just Luke comes into my life
and just is bad truth like in college he
was like getting him people are scared
of you and I was like Oh I thought I was
really nice and he like you know the
principle of solicit feedback he's been
doing that for a long time I mean he
says it like it is but you need people
like that you're
yeah 100 I think soliciting feedback
um and even you know going back to one
of the just mind-blown aha moments for
me was so I talked about you know the
coke organizations Stand Together how
they created immense value and liberated
thousands of people out of jail
um so I was at a stand together event
and I saw Charles and he's got
bodyguards around him and I'm kind of
slowly trying to say hey to him without
getting you know making eye contact the
bodyguards make sure they don't shoot me
but I I got to just shake his hand and I
and I said hey Charles I'm Gideon
um you know I just wanted to say thank
you and the first step back that night I
was texting and emailing with all your
your organizations and just how much it
meant to get that across the finish line
and he goes oh Gideon I really
appreciate that is there anything I
could be doing better
and I was like
no Charles like you've built massive
philanthropic you've created immense
value all your employees are fulfilled
in their job and reaching still
factualization but just one of the most
powerful men in the world asking me a
kind of a pleb how can how can he get
better just that so that was like holy
[ __ ] yeah and my wife and everyone in
our company always gets annoyed when I
come back from these conferences because
I come back ready to like we're not
doing enough how do we do more
um but yeah that idea and you know
solicit feedback I think it is because
we it's a slow fade into whatever good
or bad things you know you don't wake up
one day and you're a heroin addict there
was something that occurred decades ago
and so I think that's what I'm trying to
get distilled you know in our kind of
family values is solicit feedback my
kids are amazing at it and I asked them
I think there's like we can learn a lot
I take life very seriously but my kids I
always ask them
um you know hey what could I be doing
better and they're like just come play
and I've gotta I have a son with Down
syndrome and it's really hard to hear
that you're having a son the firstborn
my son is going to have Down syndrome
that was really hard to hear
um but I I got feedback from another
parent who has a child with Down
Syndrome there are Gideon you're going
to come home someday really stressed the
world business life whatever that kid's
not going to give a [ __ ] he's just going
to want to play yep and I was like oh my
God like God gave me this gift of this
child and like my son his initials are
MVP Micah Von Powell babe we made the
right decision with that name
um but he's the Envy third with their
debate I wanted to name him Acton Von
Powell v-o-n and my wife's like that is
a that is like German for of like that
makes no sense but I'm like yeah but it
sounds badass and then um so we had but
then we settled on on Micah I just think
that's a cool name yeah so MVP pretty
good initials so yeah uh talk about the
company culture because you've mentioned
a couple times and I know uh Industries
is very well known for uh being
intentional about creating company
culture what did you learn uh from
studying that organization and those
leaders and then how did you actually
change because it's interesting right
you didn't have a company culture that
you started from scratch you're like
this is the way it's going to be you had
to actually kind of build the plane
while in Flight which can be much harder
than just starting from scratch so like
walk us through like what did you learn
and how did you actually change
yeah I'll never forget there's a guy
named Dale Gibbons who was head of coke
Industries HR uh he's seen stuff and
he's just got so much wisdom and he's
all right you got to go write down your
principles because your principles
inform your culture strategy and then
everyone has a culture whether you know
it or not so when I started thinking
about these Concepts you know of course
copy what Coke did well that didn't
really works we're a different business
we're more wildcatters
um you know and we want to think a
little bit you know not we can't copy
paste stuff uh so I you know started
writing and okay let's we want humility
we want respectful communication but
I'll never forget I wrote down all this
stuff I was like hey Dale I did the hard
part I wrote it down it's like oh oh
Gideon that's cute now you gotta
effectuate it I'm like okay yeah yeah
what book can you give me you know and
it's like there's experience and but
yeah so really what we've tried to do is
move away from I mean my dad was a you
know a legend and he was the smartest
guy so he just told everyone what to do
and I think that's how a lot of every
company starts with kind of an authority
Tyrion type a good stuff done but if you
want to be successful in the long term I
think slowing down and really being
intentional with your company culture is
the most powerful way you know if you
want to go fast go alone if you want to
go far bring a team and so I think you
know we try to develop principles that
would inform you know you set the vision
which is where are we going the mission
ties everybody to the vision but then
your culture strategy informs how you
get there and principles are really the
framework to inform that and so and it's
not just you know like we have them
written down but we you know again Hans
elmrick I asked them for feedback
um and he was like yeah yeah getting a
company culture is everything and he was
like I talk about it with my guys what
are examples how can we get better
um but yeah I think soliciting feedback
you know respectful communication we're
everyone in the world we're in very fast
changing businesses our daily lives and
so one of the things that's really hard
is to tell someone how they can get
better and so what we try to do is pair
up these are all Dynamic but like okay
invite solicit feedback which invites
someone we all know we're good at but
how do we tell people you know hey
here's an area you can improve which is
very delicate communication
um and so that's where I took a a lot of
lessons from my mother which was my mom
would always say it's not what you say
it's how you say it and I think that was
just like the most powerful so we talk
about respectful Communications and I
think um the there's a book on Netflix's
culture and they uh what they said was
uh say things with positive intent and
so I think we try to really emphasize
look one everybody should be inviting
feedback how do we get better what do we
what do we learn from it
but then also how do we respectfully
communicate that is I think one of the
because nobody wants to be told what to
do but if you invite in how do I get
better it's just a lot more palatable um
and also just you know continuous
learning I mean that's kind of one of
the biggest things I mean every single
Energy company that is not thinking
about Bitcoin mining as it relates is
wrong they need to be getting feedback
this is the most revolutionary energy
technology but if you don't have a con a
culture that invites continuous learning
then you're just gonna oh well this is
the way it's always been done okay great
that's what blockbuster did where's
Blockbuster you know and so I think this
there's another concept of you know
creative destruction let's invite let's
identify businesses that can and
strategies that can disrupt our own
businesses and because I want to know
about those before you know becomes a
thing I think that's where Bitcoin
mining is like the greatest thing ever
why do you think Bitcoin mining is so
disruptive and Innovative specifically
for the oil and gas industry I think a
lot of people think of Bitcoin uh store
value they think of it as a medium of
exchange to think of it as a speculation
tool in financial markets uh but you're
specifically talking about this
intersection of Bitcoin mining and oil
and gas being such that this like match
made in heaven why is that capabilities
and so really what Bitcoin mining is is
a lot of things but it's the
democratization of energy Innovation so
if you wanted to innovate in the power
sector or an energy business
you needed to be independently wealthy
with billions of dollars or you needed
to work in a massive Corporation you're
going to work at that company for 10 20
years and you know once you can control
the purse strings you know you're
probably not going to innovate near as
much so what Bitcoin mining did is it
you leverage several principles which
you know bottom up Solutions and skin in
the game permissionless Innovation so
anybody globally now can be an energy
entrepreneur I mean literally you can
have you know there are no barriers to
entry you can rub two nickels and if you
can plug in an Asic you can innovate so
we are all thrown out I mean I remember
three years ago we were like okay what's
some of the best from a first principles
standpoint what's the lowest cost energy
okay it's waves okay well the biggest
most consistent waves are in the middle
of nowhere Sweet let's take the Bitcoin
mining there and then really there's all
these engineering Tech and this is what
we were studying five years ago was
there's these engineering technologies
that are in energy or Energy
Technologies but their their engineering
successes but they're not economic
successes and so what Bitcoin mining
does is it gives anybody a line of sight
to profitability and so really like I
like this the App Store you know before
the App Store if you want to innovate in
software you need to work at a big
oligopoly or get backed by VC or
something like that what the App Store
did was it gave a democratized
innovation in the software business so
all of a sudden you had a clear line of
sight to profitability uh if you could
innovate
and so the same thing with the Naka
motor of it basically just sent a
private you know a signal to the market
and said if you lower the cost of power
then we will give you more capital and
so really Bitcoin mining is the most
beautifully Savage Venture Capital
company and it's focused on one thing
and one thing only if you lower the
price of power you get more Bitcoin you
get more resources in your success and
so we're going to see this iterative
process play out for the next Century
Usher and a kardashev type 1 Society but
really you've democratized it
Bitcoin is a venture capital fund it's
not something most people have thought
about explain that further yeah so this
idea was popularized by a guy named
Jesse Pelton who worked on Hollow ranch
with me on the um it really was one of
the pioneers of demand response in Texas
uh so yeah basically you know Venture
Capital looks at what are disruptive
things and then how do we give capital
and make asymmetric bets and you know
you there is you know everyone wants to
go it's an efficient market it's not you
got to know people you gotta have the
networks so there's all these people
that have been disenfranchised because
they didn't go to the you know High
pedigree schools
um and so what Bitcoin mine does is it
strips out all emotions all
relationships the only thing that
matters is if you lower the price of
power then you get to you you spend less
on your operating expenses go down which
means your profit margin goes up which
you get more capital from the Bitcoin
Network through the you know the
algorithm that releases blocks every 10
minutes so you get more resources and so
if you know you have a over here they
can get power to five cents and B over
here which innovates and gets Powers
down to two cents well B is going to get
more profit and has you know more
resources and then we'll redeploy that
and so I think you know this is this is
very early but you're seeing it all of
us and now we've got this great I can
literally get on my phone and I
unfortunately do this too much oh well
that's a great idea who are the experts
like we were looking at wave stuff three
years ago oh they're all like in Europe
in London okay great and I literally got
on with three of the world's experts on
Wave turbines just like that so I think
not only do you have liquidity in the
capital markets with Bitcoin now you
don't need to have cool relationships
Communications and so I can hop on and
find experts on any idea and then you
know throw [ __ ] against the wall and see
what sticks you mentioned that Bitcoin
will have an impact on civilization as
well describe what do you mean there how
much time do you have I think I think it
you know I talk about Bitcoin point and
two Frameworks one it's an energy
Revolution
and two it's a human Freedom Revolution
and so if you live we have the greatest
Financial uh markets in America full
stop and because of that mass there's a
high amount of trust so the higher trust
can be the more value that's created
there's a company called trust Ventures
they that's like literally their concept
thank you Brian and Sal
um but really if you can Elevate trust
so but globally we that doesn't exist
you know and so like you know Nigeria
Venezuela you hear about these places
they don't have trust in their financial
systems and they can't save so if you
and now with the lightning Network and
other Innovations on bitcoin you know if
you wanted to savings is very critical
to elevating your family out of abject
poverty but if you're living in an
inflationary environment that's
impossible to do because you're always
trying to trying to saving is easy
investing is hard and so really what you
just did is you democratize savings with
Bitcoin so anybody can stack SATs
anybody all you need is a cell phone and
cell phones are super cheap thanks to
Innovation and so really you've got all
these disenfranchised
developing nations with individuals
globally who now have an opportunity to
save and knowing that their the value
they're saving cannot be printed away
and so I think this is going to play out
over the coming centuries where you know
America is the land of the free
and it was created by dissidents who
left the old world and I I think there
is mass amounts of dissonance globally
and now you've given them the greatest
human savings technology you know
anti-fragile technology I mean nobody
can shut it down so I think this is
going to play out and equip families and
individuals
um who and I think that's the beauty of
and need for education and in the market
of like Bitcoin unless you're like a Ron
Paul audit the FED person here in
America Bitcoin is is difficult to grasp
but like that was one of the greatest
things I want a few of us were invited
to the human rights uh Freedom Forum in
Oslo a few years ago and I'd hosted
dinners with my American friends I'd
hosted all these events trying to bring
education and Alex gladstein orange
killed a lot of people with some of the
events I'd host but but it was always
like yeah but I don't need it was always
a brick wall but when I went to the Oslo
freedom for him and I was like oh hey
here's what Bitcoin does they're like
okay great how do I get that like they
wanted it they need it so Innovation
happens on The Fringe so I think that's
where you know the lightning Network and
everything that's happening The
Innovation isn't going to happen in
America
um exclusively it's gonna happen where
the people need it most and when you
think about
20 30 50 years from now what does that
look like in the world is it
running on a Bitcoin standard and it's
like hyper bitcoinization is it Bitcoin
is a savings technology and people still
have other assets that they're investing
in like how do you think about it full
well-knowing predicting 50 years out is
nearly impossible yeah and so I I I I
have an opinion on the energy side but
but on the just broad Bitcoin is not
just the money you know and I'll use the
analogy when people came to America
um why why did America become so
powerful why was so much wealth created
here and I think you tie back to
property rights so when people came to
America they could own land and the
founding fathers could never have
conceptualized you know apps and social
media so how do we get well really we
had land and on top of land which is
like the base layer of Bitcoin people
built farming people built
shops built real estate but then they
built an LLC a corporation like these
are those are layer one two three on you
know of land and so none of that was
possible and then the internet comes
along and supercharged it so when I
think about the future of Bitcoin to me
it's an elevation of the principles that
made America great and so it is taking
you know the United States Constitution
and enshrining it into code to where it
set a vision and it you know it gives
more clarity and confidence to if you
create value and because ecosystem it'll
be mutually beneficial so I think
there's a lot of fascinating bitcoin's
going to intertwine with all our lives
in ways that we can't really
conceptualize but you know we'll be able
to run things in a decentralized manner
um you know on Layer Two and I'm even
hearing about layer three that just way
over my skis but on the energy side you
know all the taking the you know the
history of the oil and gas business
I mean it one of the most fun things is
the oil and gas business was pioneered
by the Texans made full stop and one of
the most fun things is talking to some
of these You Know Field guys or you know
guys that have traveled the world and
really what happened was the training
occurred in Texas and then we exported
those capabilities globally
um to where you know we were like
developing oil and gas reserves around
the world but it was largely led by the
capabilities and strategies developed by
the Americans and largely the Texans and
so the Bitcoin mine is going to play out
the same way where right now Texas is
the most important and relevant
ecosystem and really goes back to
principles and so urcot and this was so
fun my best job was I got to travel the
world
um talking about how great Texas and
ercot is and people like oh it's too hot
it's like look at physics you're all
wrong
um it doesn't matter how hot it is it's
humidity particulates but really ercot
has the most bottom-up solutions free
market Solutions of any grid globally
and really when you look at the history
it's like okay Texas is known for its
oil and gas reserves what's the largest
uh wind resource uh wind production
capacity oh it's Texas okay why well
it's because there were few barriers to
entry and the grid was set up in a way
that allowed for bottom much
entrepreneurs with the line of sight
that's not happening on the federal
level that's not happening in other rtos
where they're regulated and they're
monopolies and so you saw this Mass
value accretion out in West Texas which
is the convergence of the wind and solar
belt and so really you know now we got
18 gigawatts of solar being added next
year that you know in the ira absolutely
did it's in what it was intended to do
it's supercharged uh the economics of
Renewables
um and so really over the coming years
you know
Renewables have their issues they're the
lowest marginal cost so they have a
place but they also are unpredictable
and so Bitcoin minus this perfect load
so all the capabilities regulatory
framework and protocols that we're
developing in ercot this is we need we
need you know there is a sense of
urgency people want to get plugged in
but you're talking about ercot which is
you know a lot of people have been hired
away and you've got a convergence of
Bitcoin miners needing power more wind
and solar so huge amount of resources
are needed ercon they're doing the best
they can and they've done an amazing job
um and so really everything we're
learning on the regulatory framework
we're going to export that globally and
we're already seeing it happen I mean
there's some innovators in Kenya that
are doing demand response and so that's
what I see you know but ercot we need to
think be thinking about doubling the
peak capacity over the next couple of
decades and Bitcoin mining is a
beautiful way uh to help balance that
out you also told me that West Texas is
going to dominate the future explain
that yeah I mean
when God created the world and put Texas
down he ensured that everything all
resources and you know developed you
know everything was made for Commerce
and for industry
um and for high quality of life and
really you know you I mean I'll never
forget when we were thinking about
putting a Bitcoin mine in West Texas
it's 2017.
nobody done that and everyone told us
please don't do that and we said we hear
you but we disagree
um but I'll never forget I was trying to
get feedback for some of the people
because like there were no Services
there were no capabilities we're talking
about building in piyo Texas which is
more than an hour west of Midland there
ain't there is very little out there but
the oil and gas companies were out there
they had Services they had capabilities
so I did is I called an electrician like
five o'clock on a Friday and he called
me back around midnight I was like hey
thanks for calling me back you know but
it's late why are you coming back he
says this is a goddamn oil patch I'm 24
7. and I was like man that is a
bitcoiner he just doesn't know it yet
and so there's it's not West Texas is
going to dominate not just because of
the mass amounts of the wind and solar
build and natural gas there's these
capabilities and these this culture of
be effective and get stuff done and so
really the Bitcoin miners are going to
continue to come and everyone talks
about sustainable energy
um and its needs but we have to focus on
is this profitable because that's a
critical component of sustainability and
so when you're looking at the hyperscale
data centers or latency agnostic data
centers you know they're running out of
resources in Northern Virginia
Washington Arizona like you can't and
you know it used to be 10 megawatts I
remember the first time I told a data
center guy I was going to build 100
megawatt substation for a Bitcoin mine
he was like that's the biggest thing
I've ever heard of and I was like okay
well I don't know it's big and small so
that's what we're going to do
um but we're moving towards gigawatt
campuses in the data center industry
and so really people talk about
sustainable energy they're from a purely
on the electrons West Texas has the
highest amount of wind and solar of
anywhere outside of a few Hydro so we
talk about you know sustainability we
need to be like I don't know industry
consumes like at least 50 percent of
global energy we need you got to be
thinking about sustainable industry and
there is nothing more prolific than the
wind and solar natural gas resources of
West Texas and so as more 18 gigawatts
of solar coming on you know and it's
projected by 2030 there's going to be 74
gigawatts of additional wind and solar
in West Texas and so the Bitcoin miners
are going to continue to increase their
amount of gigawatts they're consuming
well then they turn off when people need
it more and then they're consuming
through the troughs when no one needs it
well that's going to stabilize the grid
bring on more reliable and affordable
energy and then you know the data
centers and we've actually had two
different data center companies approach
us one and I was like whoa I thought
this was going to take a decade but
they're seeing that we can get gigawatts
in one location education so and that's
that's and there's some other resource
constraints over in you know a high
population area so you've got this
convergence of a a willing and able
Workforce
the largest wind in solar resources
convergence to them so a high capacity
Factor
um and then Bitcoin miners increasing
their penetration rate to be able to
effectuate more reliable and affordable
power and I think this is something
that's going to take time so we've
actually we did a uh we're in discuss we
did a grant to help on the training for
Bitcoin miners we partnered with Texas
State technical college that was a grand
my wife and I did and that that's going
to be taking place for just Bitcoin
mining but the long-term Vision we're
already having conversations is how do
we build out the services and
capabilities that data center companies
need and I think there's a lot of
complementary capabilities I mean
managing a gigawatt Bitcoin mine in a
gigawatt data center are not the same
but they require similar capabilities
and I think that's what's so fun is like
you know the oil and gas field workers
of West Texas they know how to get [ __ ]
done and really you don't need a college
degree to be a technician at a data
center but it pays really well and so
you know talking about the Roughnecks
one of the hard things about being a
roughneck is you're always chasing the
drilling rig you know and you're on
all the time and you're missing your
kids events and it's a hard life but
you're doing what you got to do to
survive so the idea of we can put a
Bitcoin miner a Data Center and all of a
sudden that's the stability that's
Economic Development that's jobs that is
going to be coming to West Texas I mean
that's like I do this job for free and I
think that's what's going to play out
again there have literally been data
center companies that have approached it
we're like whoa we're
we're not ready but like let's have a
dialogue like how can we get better what
can we do to like ensure this happens
and you know state agencies and other
philanthropic groups we're all getting
involved in again ensuring the resources
are ready in the coming five years
you mentioned earlier that you read a
lot of books I pride myself on reading a
lot of books as well how do you pick
what books you're going to read next
well I used to read a lot of self-help
books and I'll never forget I was in
Midland it was Friday one of my friends
called me and said where are you and I
was like oh I'm at the bookstore he was
like oh God where what aisle and I was
like self-help and then he was like
idiot like please so
um I try I read less self-help books I'm
reading one book on coaching that I
really like
um but I'm really interested in stories
now I think as I've you know I'm not old
I'm only 35 but as I've gained wisdom
and experience I'm 34 year old [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I was gonna make a joke about my wife
who's a beautiful anyway I will not make
that joke
um
um but uh what kind of stories
people that have overcome adversity you
know I think it kind of goes back to I
don't know if you can see it I got a
chip on my shoulder
um but I I think
there are so many cool people in this
world that didn't have the chances I had
and I wanted I was seeing my dad die
it really re-architected my mind and I
want to be involved in a small way of
you know really ensuring like and going
back to like when I was arrested you
know I was in a really dark place you
know the internet people are mad and all
that you got people hate but my dad
looked at me and he said you messed up
but I love you
and so and I think
you know really just stories of The
Underdogs who had people that believed
in them I think that's one of the
coolest things and so I think you know
thinking about okay we can continue to
start foundations how do we start
businesses that you know and I have this
I bought this one picture
um of a buffalo and my dad as he was
passing my brother-in-law
shared this story about when a buffalo
sees a storm they don't run from the
storm they run into the storm and I so
anyway like the Buffalo has we have
socks that's the end of the storm it's
just become this really good story and
my dad took cancer head on and
um but really I bought this painting or
this picture of this Buffalo
and you know I showed it to one of our
geologists Mike dropkin and it was so
fun because he brought a new light to it
I was I liked the picture of the Buffalo
because it's standing in the snow and
it's miserable and I think that's what
you know when there's chaos when you're
in the film Adventure bitcoin's
collapsing oil's collapsing that's
really hard but if you can be peaceful
and reflect in those moments you can
create a lot of long-term value so
that's why I bought it was a show this
Buffalo just in the clearly in a
snowstorm being peaceful and you know
but what uh Mike talked about was like
see the snow on its head that's because
a buffalo will see a white landscape and
then they'll go put their head in the
snow and they'll ruffle around to look
for patches of food and I thought that
was a great metaphor for how we can
approach people
um if you were to you know meet someone
you don't know that person's story so
how do we slow down in society and
really get to know you know people's
stories you know humanize individuals
and I think that's a huge opportunity
for businesses and Venture capitalists
and private Equity is to like look do
you check the box maybe not but get to
know people spend time and understand
this guy overcame adversity like you
know I was meeting with a guy earlier
who literally came from India knew no
one and got himself into college and
then got a master's degree knew no one
and his parents you know like didn't you
know immensely help he but he came to
America and he struggled to get in
Venture Capital
um and for what I'm not exactly sure on
the reasons but it's just like I'm sure
it's difficult he's got an accent but
he's brilliant he's ambitious
um and he and you know it's funny too
because he really wants to help people
and he didn't even you know growing up
in India he didn't know
Venture Capital was a thing he didn't he
was like Oh I thought only rich people
invested rich people money in other rich
people friends and he was like then so
he was on course to be an engineer
and he you know he is a great engineer
um but then he discovered Venture
Capital he's like this is a and he
didn't use the you know the word mutual
benefit when I first met him but he's
like he can help people and in a
for-profit mutually beneficial way and
so anyway that's his vision is he wants
to start or join a private Equity
Venture Capital firm to give guys like
him
um opportunities and even though I mean
going around immigration it's insane we
disincentivized immigrant entrepreneurs
because you have to be beholden to like
the you know the hb1 Visa and like I
mean there's tons of Technology
individuals getting laid off they have
60 days to find a jobber that leaves the
country that's insane America was
founded by immigrants that is a terrible
top-down policy so any politician that's
listening you've got to re-examine that
how do we have bottom-up Solutions and
ensure that the right people are coming
into this country but how do we Equip to
allow for I mean those are the the ogs
of entrepreneurs or the people that
overcame adversity and then that
translates you know if you you know came
here you overcame adversity that
translates incredibly well to running a
startup you know and same thing I think
that's where same thing with Criminal
Justice Reform you know I think a lot of
bitcoiners are familiar with Ross
ulbrich I mean look the guy made
mistakes but he's admitted it and he's
rotting in jail that's [ __ ] up that is
hor that is an egregious and there are
so many more people like Ross that are
sitting in jail that could have been on
that were entrepreneurs and I think
that's one of the things my dad I saw
him love the oil business and that was
my North Star was find something I'm
passionate about he had a business and
that affected me but for the individuals
in society who grew up seeing someone
sell drugs or whatever that's all they
know so it'll lock those people in
prison is an egregious violation of
Human Rights
so I think there's an I think history
can you reflect on history and you can
look at who empowered the dissidents
America empowered the dissidents we
created a lot of a lot of wealth that
way and huge mistakes were made so how
do we continue to look at who's the most
disadvantaged in society and how do we
Empower them I think you know the blacks
lives matter push uh uh kicked off a few
years ago and I'm already seeing a
change in media like they got out they
said hey there's not enough of us
representing Society I mean I watched
like 10 trailers the other night every
single one of them had a hero
um that represented the black community
and I think that's the power of a vision
so I think Criminal Justice Reform
empowering those on people behind you
can't even start a business if you're in
prison that's wrong like people in
prison should be able to start a
business that could benefit their
families I mean they can learn to code
to program I think it's the same thing
so I think empowering immigrants
empowering you know individuals that
made mistakes I think that's that is a
108 way to unleash prosperity and mutual
benefit through society as is a
fascinating idea for people sitting in
prison with a bunch of time on their
hands lots of opportunity to spend time
learning to trying things right if they
can start businesses yeah and I've
actually you know a few of us uh very
um individuals that really want to
effectuate change we take a Playbook
from Silicon Valley if you don't like
something you can try to operate in that
framework and I think you know like uber
did this they're like okay can we
compete with the taxis I don't know
let's just go do it and so I think
that's one of the most fun things we've
been talking about for years and it was
one of the most fun checks I've ever
ridden in my entire life
a few of us a few years ago decided
prisons are messed up and we can spend
millions of dollars and not change the
laws what if we started Our Own Prison
company so I literally set out to start
a a for-profit prison company which
people hear them they're like oh
for-profit that's bad it's like look do
you know what the incentives are the
for-profit uh prisons are incentivized
to keep you in prison they make money
the more people that go to prison and so
there are huge unintended consequences
so it's not our for-profit person's bad
our non-profit person's bad it's culture
it's strategy it's incentives so one
thing we a few of us this was not my
idea we came a lot of us like what if we
started a for-profit prisoners that it
wasn't paid per individual it was how do
if we lowered the recidivism rate of
that individual we got a Delta on the
back end of that profit
and I think that was that was like an
interesting kpi so that was a few of us
had that idea uh and then a few got
feedback a few of my friends were like
look idiot and this was pitched to a few
very wealthy individuals that everybody
knows and they all turned it down
because of Optics it's like we can't be
seen investing in a prison deal I was
like look I'm getting pal I don't give a
damn this will effectuate human
Prosperity let's figure out how to do
this thing so just been putting that
idea out there and a few months ago I
got introduced
um to Brian and social profit
Corrections SPC and and it was so
unbelievably energizing he was worked at
a prison he saw the atrocity he kept
trying to get more resources to the
mental health because basically the the
you know we all feel sorry for kids and
Trauma when they're kids but then they
reach a certain age and it's like we
can't feel feeling sorry for him and we
throw him in jail and so I think that's
where one of my proudest Investments and
so anyway Brian pitched me on a hey so
he registered as a 501c3 and I was like
look I really want to do this as
for-profit he was like here's why that's
a bad idea and the the Optics and so but
he's like look and this one I was like
oh God I have to write this guy a check
and I love it he's like look Gideon as a
non-profit we'll have a lower cost to
Capital so we'll be able to out-compete
all these for-profit companies that are
bidding on contract and I was like oh my
God I'm not supposed to do this but okay
here's a three-year commitment 250 000 a
year let's go
um and people know and so how does it
work it's a non-profit prison yeah it's
an operating non-profit 501c3 okay and
there's a physical location obviously no
not yet so that was another thing is it
was like the architecture we need to
reimagine like look yes people messed up
in that matter but when you walk into a
prison how the how do you design a
building can absolutely affect your
mental disposition
um so what Brian what my long-term
vision is to literally buy raw land and
build you know prisons uh from the
ground up with an intentionality towards
you know getting the extra sunlight
making it and this is not something
you'd start are you know you'd start
with low level offenders and learn but
it's like day one when someone shows up
to a prison we want that person to know
look you messed up but you're a human
and you matter and to have you know
these capabilities within the prison and
that was another
you know I was very angry I wanted to
change society and so I was like okay
when I when I can have Financial
Resources I'm going to hire attorneys
and represent non-violent drug offenders
that was you know kind of why we got
involved in uh with Brittany Barnett and
the Buried Alive Foundation
but and people used to say well Gideon
and gratefully still people had concerns
over that they're like well what happens
when they get out of prison and I used
to say I don't give a [ __ ] let's just
get him out not a good answer and that's
where you've got to think
multi-dimensional it does matter how do
we get every everyone who shows up the
resources and the opportunity to better
themselves and I think that's what
Brian's vision is is he's worked at a
prison like I'm a nerd who has an idea
ideas are cute but there's way too many
of them how do you execute so Brian has
operating capabilities he's layered in
some mental health capabilities and I
think that's what I'm most excited about
in the next multi-decades is the
convergence of Criminal Justice Reform
and mental health and that's something
that's very passionate to my wife and I
and so I think you know that's that was
Brian's Vision was like and nobody
nobody wanted to be the first check
everyone loves to follow and so really
my experience in Bitcoin mining and
trying to raise money a little early was
nobody likes to be the first so I think
that's informed my I think one of our
capabilities is like if we can see your
vision you have complementary
capabilities and shared values like
let's go and so anyway we wrote a check
to Brian he's been traveling he's
meeting with other investors
um but yeah he wants to day one and I've
been teaming I've been connecting him
just just send him on emails hey here's
a mental health profession The Meadows
Foundation they are the experts in
mental health and how do we get better
um and you know I mean mental health
you're dealing with multi-generational
trauma that's what largely is feeding
the industrial Prison Complex and so
that's what Brian's going to do is he's
looking to win a contract and manage a
prison
um and there's a huge need for that and
so and even he was like hey he texted me
like hey there's a prison for sale up in
this area I was like great let's try to
buy it like I mean what what can we do
and so that's kind of where he is he's
up and running he's trying to bring in
more investors uh what is it called
social profit Corrections like it's like
spc.org yeah that's pretty pretty good
uh yeah it's awesome and it's just a
slight tweak you know it is
it's not a for-profit it but it's going
to create mutually beneficial value
through Society so writing that check
was like one of the just awesomest
things it's mutually beneficial
I'm a nerd I want I want to try crazy
[ __ ] and I want it to work in the long
term but I can't do that myself so I
think that's the beautiful thing about
Communications share a vision it was the
same thing on that deal I did my wife
and I did for education I was on a panel
at a Bitcoin Commons Event in Austin I
said hey I don't know how to build
education stuff but we'd like to support
something at a college or a high school
or whatever and then a few months later
someone's like hey we hear you like this
idea I was like okay great you all have
capabilities I don't
um so yeah just putting ideas out there
there's a there's plenty to do in this
world there's a hell of a lot to do
where can we send somebody to find you
on the internet if they want to find out
more about what you're doing and energy
with Bitcoin mining or with some of the
philanthropic work
um I'm a tweet so Gideon oh pal and then
I also post a lot of memes on LinkedIn
um you're a LinkedIn Meme Maker yeah I
think and if anyone at LinkedIn or
Microsoft is listening y'all guys don't
support GIFs that's a huge problem and
additionally you're a thoughtful Meme
Maker yeah I mean we have to I think and
I pair it with memes I think memes are
so powerful there's a lot of stuff I
struggle to communicate sometimes but I
can I can effectuate very clear way of
thinking with you know my mamatic art
and so I think there's a lot a lot you
know I never forget I wasn't some Bible
studying this guy was like oh kids these
days are ruining the human language and
I'm like well we used to like paint and
he he was like talking about how he went
from pictographs to You Know spoken word
and written language and now we're going
back with memes and I was like dude I
don't know if you've ever made a meme
but like it can communicate things
so amazingly more effectively so yeah so
LinkedIn support gifts that's a huge
deal but also your user interface like
yo y'all can't when I try to post a meme
I have to dig all the way through my
whole picture album I can't go to my
various meme categories so I think a
better user interface
um if you but again if you know if you'd
like feedback holler at me it just
empower the meme makers and you'll be in
a better position yeah I say it all the
time the memes are the message right and
and uh if you think the world's richest
man or one of the top three richest men
in the world is probably one of the most
lethal meme Lords Elon Musk and uh
whatever people think about him he was
asked in a Bloomberg uh interview a
couple years ago
would you rather be a billionaire or a
meme Lord and of course it's easy for a
billionaire to say meme Lord but he
chose meme Lord and I tend to think that
uh you can have a billion dollars but
not everyone can make just a [ __ ]
awesome meme yeah I think that's gonna I
I'm I have several business ideas I want
to start around memes Caleb I'm not
starting them this year
um but there's there's so much
opportunity to take you know from the
sports industry and capabilities there
and apply them to memers you know I
think there's a lot there's just so much
to do in this world but but
um yeah
I love it well thank you so much for
your time I appreciate it I learned
something every time I've talked with
you
um and uh I tend to think that uh we
need more people like you who believe
the uh Bottoms Up individual approach uh
to problem solving the incentives uh and
really just kind of the continued
embracing of the American democratic
ideals uh is incredibly important so I
appreciate all the work you're doing and
we'll have to do this again in the
future yeah appreciate the the platform
so thank you